now there is increasing chatter in
Westminster that a general election
could be the only way to break the
brexit deadlock so with that in mind I
travel to a key swing state
if apes which to engage the mood of
people there
this is England's oldest continually
inhabited town boasting a rich maritime
history and an ancient port that has
historically had close links with
northwestern Europe it also has a knack
of choosing the winning party at general
elections in 2017 labour won this
bellwether marginal from the
Conservatives by just eight hundred and
thirty one votes so how are people
feeling now I've voted to remain in
Europe I still feel that way I feel that
the referendum we had was lacking in the
information which we now have and
therefore I feel we need a second friend
him but this may be what's happening in
Westminster
what's your sense on who's gonna win
next time if there is an election cuz
they could be Wow okay we feel the same
with Jeremy Corbyn we keep changing
issues so you sort of think well perhaps
he's got big speaking sense and then
your change and you think well I don't
know so much really I think it's very
confused yeah it is very confusing
you're not really sure what there was
another election I'm not really sure
what a Miss I think all the other
countries must be laughing at as I think
it's the thing that's been going on
since 2016 and they say and it's gonna
carry on longer you know that's
definitely the government
let me say I think she should resign do
you think that definitely if you voted
conservative before you conservative
voters yes yes yeah anyone in particular
I'd like to see Nigel Farage I think he
would get you're safe with this mess the
frustration with Theresa May is
reflected at the Ipswich Conservative
Club across the country local
associations are flexing their muscles
demanding their MPs and the Prime
Minister listen to them on brexit we do
risk losing the trust of the people and
that comes down to local level as well
and I think if you'd lose your trust in
your electorate elected representatives
whether they're councillors county
councillors MPs that's when things start
to go wrong and you can almost get very
populist candidates standing on very
single issues so why is it there's lots
of trust happening because there's been
a delay or cause people think breaks it
might not happen or people just don't
like the way it's been dealt with on the
on the doorstep and it is from leavers
and remainders seems to be that
politicians aren't actually listening to
what the public is saying and what the
public are wanting or respecting the
referendum of the result missus Murray's
made a very poor job of the whole thing
and the negotiating I was down at
Downing Street and I asked how many of
the people negotiating were remain is
the deal and every one was a remainder
well how you can possibly how can that
possibly be right it's not like they're
certainly not attractive coming from you
I don't necessarily think that's just
from the Conservatives I mean I think
and this is biggest part of the issue
and the central parties need to realize
this all the major central parties are
that it's the associations and the
members that actually vote for the lead
authorities we have that we had the
changes a few years ago which men these
members that directly um vote for the
leaders and actually we're also the
activists we're also the people that do
the work and go out through our doors
and if they're not listening to us
really that means they're not listening
to the people either the Conservative
candidate is also worries the chaos in
Westminster might turn off voters I was
a real desire for people who I talk to
for X it to be delivered and for us to
get on with it so are you frustrated
than by the delayed well I mean it's I
mean clearly I voted to leave European
Union so I you know I want us to leave
at the end of March I hope that's still
possible 58% of people in Ipswich waited
to you leaving European Union I'm so
clearly I think it's very important for
this country and very important for
democracy especially in this country for
us to get on with it levy European Union
start focusing on other issues and start
being the great country we know we are
well the Labour leadership have
expressed that their preferred option to
break the deadlock here at Westminster
is a general election the local MP is
concerned about the timing
I don't want an election this year no I
mean I'm I whatever whatever the
leadership of my party is saying it
actually makes no sense to have an
election until we know what situation we
are in with Europe because at the moment
it's that's not the point the main point
at the moment is to get resolve the
situation with Europe and then once
we've resolved the situation with Europe
I would like to see the earliest
possible general election because quite
apart from the mess with Europe I think
the mess that they tore is a
electing all the people of this country
within continuing austerity with the 10%
of the population getting richer and
richer and everybody else getting poorer
and poorer that has to be the thing that
people want to vote on after spending
the day in Ipswich I can see why it's a
bellwether we've got the full spectrum
of views here and wherever we went there
was an exasperation and really a
disbelief with what's happening in
Westminster if any party manages to put
forward a cohesive vision for the
country then votes in this swing seat
and therefore the taking